it's a blast from parties past
and you're invited ready for another
round of mario party mayhem
of course you are it's a superstar
collection of mario party boards and
mini games
live it up on five classic boards from
the nintendo 64 era
including peach's birthday cake and
space land
each board is packed with zany events
guaranteed to keep you on your toes
and when we say zany we mean it
jump connect blocks
and give facelifts in hilarious
over-the-top mini-games
all of which support button controls
with 100 mini-games from the mario party
series catalog
you'll have a blast in this all-star fun
fest
here's a little party favor all game
modes work with online play
even if you're partying solo you can
randomly match with other partygoers
worldwide
playing a board game online with friends
save your progress mid-game
grab a snack then resume the festivities
stickers are also available to
communicate with others
it's time to partay in mario party
superstars
launching on the nintendo switch system
october 29th
pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop